el anuncio era muy esperado
especialmente después de las
declaraciones de la comisión alemana de
vacunación que el jueves desaconsejó la
vacuna de astrazéneca para mayores de 65
años citando datos insuficientes
finalmente el viernes se conoció el
veredicto del regulador europeo la
vacuna del laboratorio británico
astrazéneca está aprobada para su uso en
la unión europea a partir de los 18 años
según los ensayos su eficacia es de un
60% es la tercera vacuna que recibe la
luz verde de la agencia europea de
medicamentos tras la de facer variante y
moderna story of fire fire and sounds es
un verdadero placer estar aquí y
anunciar el tercer dictamen positivo
para la autorización de la vacuna contra
el cob y 19 de astrazéneca esto amplía
la gama de vacunas disponibles para los
estados miembros de la unión europea y
del espacio económico europeo que
ayudarán a controlar la pandemia ya
proteger a los ciudadanos del prohuerta
que éstos opten una decisión que se
produce en un momento en el que la
empresa farmacéutica está siendo
criticada por los dirigentes europeos
por el retraso de las entregas
tras el anuncio bruselas autor
el uso del suero de astrazéneca en la
unión europea'
acabamos de autorizar la vacuna de
astrazéneca en el mercado de la unión
europea tras una evaluación positiva de
la ema espero que la empresa entregue
las 400 millones de dosis acordadas
seguiremos haciendo todo lo posible para
asegurar las vacunas para los europeos
nuestros vecinos y socios en todo el
mundo esta es una decisión muy esperada
la inyección es más económica y también
más fácil de transportar y almacenar la
siguiente vacuna que podría ser validada
por la ema es la de johnson and johnson
pero tanto en europa como en el resto
del mundo continúan las preocupaciones
sobre si serán realmente eficientes
estas vacunas contra las variantes del
coronavirus